so i missed the bus so i had to take a
cab and the prices were much higher
because of the
strikes and everything so that added a
bit to the stress because i have an exam
two and i also have a friend who is like
30 minutes late because of the train
strikes too so it's really affecting us
but 30 minutes late for her exactly yeah
like she's coming right now but it's
like other times about to start so it's
affecting like all of us how do you feel
about that must be the last that's the
last thing you need right when you've
got an exam it's really stressful
because you want to be focusing on your
revision instead of like
getting to school on time
luckily i was able to come a bit earlier
for my exam because i did leave the
house by an hour earlier than i would
usually
but i can definitely like see the added
stress when you're trying to revise for
your exam but also trying to get to
school on time everything's a bit
stressful but you just have to kind of
try and balance things